I think out of everything
[Music]
she was worried about me do you know
what I mean like that was her last
thought like
[Music]
Davina McCall she's a TV presenter a
fitness fanatic multiple times
best-selling author rarely off our
televisions and what you see is what you
get it's good to be back after big
brother I thought what else can I do to
get famous so I was always a bit of a
show-off mum you made a mistake how
great I am that's at the back of
everything why
I did cope with my mum at 15. I did it
with my sister at 14. you were doing
drugs yeah like all drugs all my
problems I left my job no money I had
nothing I will literally do anything to
stop feeling like this I'm gonna find
someone for help I'm [ __ ]
ten years ago you lost Caroline
your half-sister it was definitely the
worst thing that ever happened to me
I was just trying to be really strong
for her and I kept saying to her I'm
gonna be fine
she'd put a fence around her and I
thought I'm [ __ ] climbing over the
fence and I'm gonna get in don't wait
for somebody to say that you've got six
weeks to live because the best seven
weeks of my life with my sister were
those last seven weeks of hers
quick one at the start of these episodes
I told you that 74 of people who watch
this channel frequently haven't yet hit
the Subscribe button and I told you that
the bigger the channel gets the better
the guests get and hopefully I've
delivered upon that for you so there's
two things I wanted to tell you the
first is if you've ever enjoyed this
channel could you do me a favor and my
team here a favor which is hit that
subscribe button because it helps this
channel more than you know and as I say
the bigger the channel the better the
guest but also we're approaching 1
million subscribers and when we hit 1
million subscribers
we've been working for many months to do
something very big in which you're all
invited to
I'll reveal that when we hit a million
subscribers
enjoy this episode tavino
[Music]
what was your first
defining
moment
oh
um definitely
uh realizing the moment I realized my
mum wasn't coming back to pick me up so
I got taken to my granny's my paternal
grandmother most amazing woman called
pippy
got taken to her house in the country
which I knew really well I used to spend
quite a lot of time down there with her
and my mum wasn't with my dad she was
with another man but I didn't kind of
question that they'd spit up but I
didn't I didn't know that or kind of
understand I don't think in my head I
realized what was going on
and she said I'm going on on holiday
and you know I'll be I'll be back
and I was like okay great and I stayed
with my granny and then after a couple
of months I thought
she coming back but then I thought I
didn't want to this was such a different
time you know I'm 55 so this would have
been over 50 years ago
it was such a different time that you
didn't ask people children didn't go
where's Mommy gone or when's mummy
coming back
I knew that I was a guest at my Granny's
house but I wasn't it had all been
planned my granny had been given my
custody my dad was coming down every
weekend to be with me
um they were sort of sharing custody but
my dad was trying to make money in
London and my granny was taking care of
me day to day
and it had all been sorted but I didn't
know that because they just thought well
she's young she won't really remember or
realize let's all just brush it under
the carpet and it's so interesting
because nowadays with my children
everything that happens we're like how
do you feel about that are you okay
let's talk it through blah blah blah
just didn't happen back in those days so
I grew up thinking that my mum had left
me
um and had enough come back so at about
probably four maybe six months after
after she'd gone
I realized that I wasn't gonna live with
her again but I was left feeling guilty
because I felt like my granny was
looking after me
and
she didn't want me in some way like not
that she didn't she was so loving to me
but somehow I was overstaying my welcome
so I think that was a defining moment
because it's set up a chain of events a
fear of Abandonment that kind of made me
make some really stupid decisions all
through my teenage years into my
twenties
um
and and something that I've worked
diligently on since my early 20s to let
go of
why did your mother do that
well my mum
grew up in France with two parents who
were very loving but didn't know how to
um
give her their time
so I think my mum needed
time and contact but they just gave her
a lot of money they were they were quite
wealthy and they just you know at 18
they gave her a lump sum of money she
went spent the whole lot on clothes and
each other on she got a food disorder
she's very thin it was the 60s she was
like a model she had a fade done away
nose job she she was incredible looking
lots of drugs quite a lot of drink like
crazy fun lady met my dad my dad was
super hot like young guy they were an IT
couple he was so in love with her she
was completely out I could probably a
sex addict when I when I looked back at
her life and unashamedly so the French
very she's French French are very
different about sex she was kind of you
know she was it's only bodies that was
her catchphrase like
you know oh
it's only bodies and you'd think no
that's someone's husband like that is
you know David so looking back she she
wasn't well herself but she was so young
like this was we're talking 22 23 when
she met my dad she'd already had a child
at 16 been forced to marry the father of
that child they'd got divorced then she
met my dad so she was
troubled herself right
and my Dad tried to help fix her but it
just wasn't going to work and she ran
off with someone else
um having had several Affairs and
everything and my dad was broken-hearted
absolutely broken-hearted and the courts
in the UK because I was born in the UK
and had been brought up here gave my
granny and my dad custody which was so
rare
so
um
I I I'm not sure how hard she fought I'm
not sure that she did but
um that was what happened but I did go
and see her in the holidays but that was
quite crazy like what did you see I oh
my God like what didn't I see I mean my
mum would
she would wear this was quite a Funny
Story I mean in some of it makes me
laugh now but it would be she'd go out
with me like in a floor-length electric
blue coat
and we'd get out and then she'd go like
that to someone and I'd think she'd
flash my God she's naked yes like she'd
be naked underneath her coat and she'd
flash someone she'd think it was
hilarious
and I'd just be like oh God somebody
please like make the world disappear
but at times
it's really hard to explain but I loved
my mother
like I really wanted her to pull some
mummy
business out the bag like I was like
come on
you can do this and
sometimes she'd give me a hug and I'd
think oh my God this is it like this is
what it feels like to be hugged by
mother but then other times you'd be
reading her right it'd be like well I've
got to be
I've got to be a sweet little girl oh no
I'm gonna have to take care of you well
like now I have to be really good fun
I've got I need to entertain you it's
always weighing a thousand different
hats to see how she was going and my
granny used to say to me when we did
start talking about it when I was older
she said we'd have to like
kind of it would be funny for a month
when you came back from France you'd be
a little bit on edge and we'd have to
just really get you back into your
favorite foods a routine at bedtime
safety re-ground me
so when I say I'm half done half Wild
Child it's because of that life that
I've had like
drugs at 12 with my mum like you were
doing drugs yeah like smoking weed at 12
Coke at 15 14. even I did cope with my
mum at 15. I did it with my sister at 14
you know it was like it was there was no
and then I'd get back to the UK and it
would it would be back into your
second-hand clothes and sort of safe
small life like simple my life was very
simple I mean I say secondhand clothes
just to give you an idea I was in my
grandad's jumper and an old pair of
jeans and I get to Paris and they go
what are you wearing his loads of money
go and buy some Posh loafers and get
your hair done and I'm 12 like I look
like a proper Lolita but I and I'd
quickly realized that my life in Paris
and my life in in the UK they must never
know about each other because if if they
knew
in the UK about my life in Paris they
wouldn't let me see my mum and I didn't
care how mad she was
I still wanted to see her that does that
make sense yeah
so my sister also was my lifeline in
Paris so my sister who's six years older
than me even though we did do drugs
together and I know that sounds bad but
she was my rock like she was my she
grounded me when I was in Paris so we
stuck together we understood what mum
was like we worked her together Caroline
yeah Caroline yeah
and then my mum you know but I I did
like going to Paris and also because I
was young and they didn't stop me from
doing anything it's crazy
having sat here with um stand-up
comedians I remember Jimmy Carter said
to me he said often it's assumed that
comedians themselves are depressed and
that they're cracking jokes to kind of
cheer other people up in an attempt to
cheer themselves up but he said to me
you should actually ask them which one
of their parents is depressed which one
of their parents were they trying to
please and entertain
you said earlier you know did I have to
be this one day or did I have to be a
joker did I have to take care of her was
your personality shape but that that
desire to
so to keep her in good spirits we'll win
over her affection
I think it taught me some amazing skills
and reading people
so um also my granny was unbelievably
good at this as well so people used to
think my granny was psychic because
somebody would walk in the room and
she'd go are you okay and they'd walk in
smiling but there would be a an eyebrow
raise or a flicker of an eye or
something and she'd go
you're right and they go oh God
like read me you can see straight to him
I feel like being with my mother she
could walk I could hear by the way she
walked
what person she was going to be when she
walked through the door I could hear the
steps coming and I'd think I know how to
behave the minute she walks through that
door
it's an amazing gift
and that's how I choose to see
everything that's happened to me I am
absolutely not a victim sure some of
it's been hard and it's like you said
I'm happy we were talking just before we
started I'm happy and yes life throws me
curveballs
but I choose to learn from those and
still be happy rather than cling onto
the curveball and let it pull me down
but I often wonder whether it's it was
the hardship
that made me when you know small wins or
little winds in my life were massive oh
yeah you know a hug from my mum that
felt a little bit like a parental hug
rather than a needy or an angry or
that would be a huge like I'd done out
on that for a month I'd be like but yeah
but I got a hug two weeks ago that was
epic
you know so I think you hold on to these
little things but I don't know some kids
might not they might not see or feel
that thing because they don't have that
in them I wonder whether we are born
with it it's such an interesting
concept positivity can you make yourself
positive
if you aren't
that have you ever spoken to the
speakmans I remember going on this
morning the speakmans are a couple Nick
and Eva
they're on this morning as kind of
psychology experts they kind of they're
like they help you train yourself out of
patterns of behavior those guys said
something that if you are a negative
person at the end of you know it's
raining and it's raining for the third
day in a row
you finish your negative sentence with
but luckily
and you have to say but luckily and then
think of something but luckily
but luckily it was so dry in the summer
it does mean that the reservoirs will be
full and you finish every negative
thought with a positive and they said it
takes about two to three weeks
to naturally start thinking but you know
that's probably not a bad thing
but it's just remembering to do that is
so hard
when you were when you were like 16 17
you know you said you'd started doing
drugs with your mother in in France but
what did you want to be when you were
older if I'd asked yourself I probably
probably need to clarify actually that
me and my mum only did drugs twice okay
I mean I know that's twice times too
many in my book but
I don't want to give this impression
that she and I were taking tons of drugs
together because that would be a false
impression okay
I just needed to plant so that put that
there yeah but
um
what did I want to be when I was 16.
yeah I was quite nihilistic I think in a
way I wasn't thinking about anything
except for the weekend
and where was I going to go and what
club could I go to and how could I go
out and what how could I party and that
was beginning I moved to London when I
was nearly 14. and when I moved to
London suddenly the safety of the
country had disappeared and I started
finding ways to go out and take drugs
and find people that took drugs in
London
I was living with my dad my stepmom and
they were very kind of solid straight
people but
my life did slightly change then so I
wasn't really thinking about anything at
that point really the time when I
started forming
an idea and I was basically just a
show-off would have been 18. I was
basically just a show-off yeah
um because
I think because I had this fear of
abandonment
if I was if I did look at me look at me
enough look at me I'm here everybody
don't leave me ah needy people pleaser
everybody like me like that that's what
that's who I was and actually what drugs
did for me at that time
was they made me feel
safe
they made me feel like I was being
hugged in that maternal way that they
filled this hole that I had here and
then as soon as the drug started running
out the hole would feel like sort of the
hole would be there again and I think oh
my God where's the nearest thing I can
get you know
um man laughter attention drug like help
fill the hole so I was always a bit of a
kind of
you know a bit of a show-off
and at 18 you drop out of University
nearly went to University
um didn't go to university
and this is always something that I
want to say to to kids I didn't really
know what I was doing I was an absolute
car crash I would say until I was 23 24
. so when I was 19
I
um I'd left school I went to Australia
for a few months
I came back and I thought I'm going to
save up money I'm going to get you know
go working I'm going to save up some
money I'm going to try and get enough
money to go back to Australia and live
there I loved it out there I was clean I
wasn't taking any drugs I was just
driving to the beat I mean it was such a
different me and I liked that me that
was the nun like my nun was freed in
Australia and I thought I quite like
this person I like who I am
and then A girlfriend of mine said
I'm going to Santa pay for two weeks do
you want to come and I was like yeah but
I haven't got much money because I had
all my savings and stuff and I didn't
want to delve into that she had quite a
lot of money and bless her she came on
the coach with me from Victoria down to
Santa pay and her parents had a house
there and then I started dipping into
the savings and then in two weeks I'd
spunked
800 pounds that I'd saved up for my
flight to go back to Australia and I
never went back and that was a kind of
you know that was the Wild Child me
dancing on tables in the Capture One
Santa pay until God knows what time in
the morning hitching a lift off people
in Ferraris trying to get back to I mean
awful danger danger danger everywhere
how I'm still alive I've got no idea
um
but hilarious you know it was just part
of my path but that meant that I never
went back to Australia and I I got a job
as a waitress I was a really really good
waitress
I loved waitressing did you ever do that
well my mum had a restaurant when I was
super young so I did did it a little bit
but I was so young that it was I was
more just of a gimmick you know he'll
get loads of tips because he's yeah
um but not not properly no I learned a
lot I bet you did
um I learned a ton from working in that
restaurant yeah about people in customer
service and stuff and then I worked in
like you know there was a shop called
Republic like retail a lot I worked a
lot I did that as well what did you
learn
um well just people I mean people skills
and what people want and that the
customers the most important person you
said people pleaser yeah I mean that's
my natural that was my natural habitat
so I'd go and I'd like make people feel
amazing while they're having their meal
and make sure that they had the best
service ever and it felt like a win to
me you know at the end of the night I
thought I've done a really good job I've
made loads of people really happy and
that made me feel good about myself so
it was a great job for me
when did you first realize that you
wanted to do something in media TV
um or was it more yeah no so that that's
quite a good story so I was working I
got a job at models one after the after
the and it was by chance it was complete
fluke I got a job at models one working
on Stephen
the mail model section at models one I
was a Booker for the male models I mean
I'm telling you 19 or 20 year old me
walking in there I was like
this is the best
of her all these gorgeous men okay I
fell in love every 30 seconds for the
first week
um and then what was interesting it just
became they just became normal I was
like oh there's another good looking guy
whatever
um desensitized yeah it's fun it's so
funny though how quickly that happens
but I'm still friends with loads of them
now again it was a great time in my life
slightly car crashed lots of drugs lots
of kind of Madness but also a very
kind of good time and time in terms of
work and having fun so I was at this
agency loads of beautiful models
everywhere I get approached by this guy
who knows I love music and he said you
want to run a club with me at
subterranea and I said yeah great and he
said bring all the beautiful people so
these club nights
caught the attention of somebody at MTV
who was going to launch MTV Europe and
they needed to for the launch of MTU TV
Europe and Amsterdam get loads of
celebrities from the UK to Amsterdam but
do it in a really cool MTV way
so me and this girl called Sarah
blondstein and
um a guy called Graham we were in charge
of entertaining the celebrities from
Victoria train station to Amsterdam and
back
and it was like Duran Duran
um zodiac mind warp I mean it was really
really fun
and I dressed up as a cleaning lady
lipstick on my teeth curlers in my hair
a tea earn full of champagne and it was
riotous and at the end of that night
when we were heading back
um from Amsterdam on the plane
I thought to myself
I'm gonna work at MTV that is the best
place
those are the best people and while I
was there at that night and this is
what this is another defining moment
that night when I'd gone
I said to someone can I get your number
because I'd love to kind of look at job
prospects at MTV would it be all right
and he's like yeah sure
like I had the number and I thought I'm
gonna I'm gonna call this guy and then I
called him and I said you know would it
be all right can I um to sort of send
you a Show reel if I did a show will
because I'd like to be a presenter on I
didn't even know the word Vijay then on
MTV and he was like yeah sure sure
and I started making show reels and I
must have sent him like
three a year and relentlessly called him
until he said please stop calling me
after a couple of years he said could
you just
like I can't give you a job at the
moment we only want European presenters
and I said can you give me someone
else's number
and I'll call them instead and he went
yeah you can take Mike Catherine's
number so I took my Catherine's number
and eventually a year later Mike Calvin
said
there's a vacancy so I'm 24.
I've just got clean
I'm I'm six months clean and sober I'm
absolutely radioactive I can't believe
I'm sober I still can't believe I'm
waking up with dry sheets
that my pillow you know we're talking
about small wins my sheets were dry in
the morning and I'd know when I woke up
and I saw daylight and I think I know
this is morning
this is amazing that's such a win I
think it's so dry yeah sweating I used
to sweat in bed withdrawing at night and
my sheets were dry is this what what
drug causes that so heroin so I I was
um in the end
um addicted to heroin for maybe the last
three months of my using but the nun
took over I think at that point and was
like you are addicted now you have to
stop what was that moment that where and
what was can you really zoom in on that
moment of you reach a point and you go
this has to change
[Music]
so my best friend had said she was going
to take me to Santana she didn't use or
drink really she'd Had a Brain Injury
when she was younger and she couldn't
for 10 years so she didn't
and she got me into her car and I was
like I'm so excited about going to see
Santana I was probably what Santana um
it's a band ah
Stephen Bartlett I know sorry go and do
some revision okay can you just say
something
sometime I'm gonna like them really okay
um and
I got in the car
and she shut the doors and she said I'm
actually not going to take you to
Santana
I need to tell you some things I was
like yeah and she said
I know that you've been lying to me
weirdly I'd been off heroin for a month
at that point because I'd been away I'd
done a geographical I've gone away
looking after someone's uh nanny for
someone for two weeks and got clean and
then I'd I'd also been with my mum in
Morocco so I had no heroin for a month
but I had just come off the back of a
24-hour cocaine vendor which had made me
realize that heroin wasn't my problem
all drugs were my problem if I if I
wasn't taking heroin I couldn't take
cocaine normally either I I couldn't
just take it for four hours and then go
to bed I had to take it for 24 hours I
was an animal I thought oh my God I'm
I'm not just addicted to heroin heroin's
not it's all drugs I've got to stop
she gets me in the car and she goes I
know you've been lying to me we all know
you've been lying to us all your friends
and you are the topic of conversation at
every dinner party I go to and this
shame
starts piling on and I
I
started feeling a bit well [ __ ] you to
her and this is this is virtually my
only friend I've got left
and I do say well [ __ ] you like
[ __ ] you I didn't really know what to
say because I couldn't really argue with
what she was saying
and I said yo I didn't want to go and
see something really childish like I
didn't want to go and see Santana anyway
get out the car I'm trying to get out
the car she's slightly shut the doors
it's all eggy awkward slam the door walk
away from her immediately burst into
tears and think I'm not gonna turn back
around and let her see I'm crying you
know get inside go straight to bed my
parents you know I was um sleeping on a
camp bed in my in my dad's sort of
wardrobe I'd move out of my boyfriend's
home
his fault that I was using I'd got worse
I'd left my job I thought that was the
thing that was making me use I'd got
worse I had a car but no money to put
Petrol in the car I had not put nothing
I was on this Camp bed and I was sort of
walk into the like my room which wasn't
really room it was a cupboard
sit on the bed go to sleep
and then an hour later I wake up and I
think I'm gonna find someone for help
I'm [ __ ] I can't do this anymore I
phoned this woman who I knew was clean
and it was as if she'd been expecting my
call she goes oh hi Davina
and I was like I was just wondering if
you're going to a meeting
um tomorrow she's like yeah yeah I'm
going at six o'clock you know World's
End come and meet me there
I was like oh yeah you know I'm just
interested to see what you know like
what it's like it's just yeah great come
along if you want
she didn't ask me what's going on she
didn't ask which was exactly right
and the next morning I woke up
and I felt so full of Shame and I
thought I'll go and see Sarah so I went
to see Sarah at work at lunchtime
sobbed I said I'm not expecting you to
believe me
and I know I'm gonna have to prove
myself but I just wanted to let you know
I want to change and I want to do
something about it and I'm going to go
to a meeting tonight and I could see a
slight sort of
are you really like is this really gonna
happen I just thought I I don't know how
much more I can give you tell you but I
really really mean it so I went to a
meeting that night
just spent the next two weeks going to
meetings every day well and for 90 days
after sobbing just sobbing in every
meeting of surrender
I don't care what I have to do I will
literally do anything to stop feeling
like this and N A taught me how to live
and how to change
and how to heal myself I I owe an a my
life literally
but it also gave me my career
and weirdly having tried to get a job at
MTV while I was using all those years
the the time they say come in for an
interview we're going to finally screen
test you after three years of trying I
was six months clean
and I didn't mess it up you know I
turned up on time in fact I turned up a
bit early that was new for me
um I turned up clean and smelling like
flowers and with a smile on my face and
color in my cheeks that was new for me
you said and I taught you how to heal
what did you learn about healing
and what did you learn about why you
were
addicted to narcotics hmm well I learned
about fear of Abandonment I probably
hadn't heard that as a phrase
then I didn't understand from listening
to other people talk about their
experiences sometimes I think oh no that
wasn't quite my experience I don't think
that's why I used and then I remember
hearing someone and thinking
that's exactly me that whole and it
never fills up and you're constantly
trying to fill it with anything and then
when they said here is where I'm
learning to fill it myself and I thought
that's what I want I want to line the
whole with something impermeable
that means it will fill up and never
empty again
and there are steps in Narcotics
Anonymous and any 12-step program and
you know if you work through these steps
and it is like people would go oh it's
like a cult you know it's really bad but
I did replace my addiction with
addiction to Narcotics Anonymous but I
know which addiction I'd rather have
like
I went all the time often twice a day
because it was the only place where I
felt completely normal I'd be around
other people going yeah I felt like that
oh yeah I did that oh God I messed up
this or oh yeah I had
um
you know Liaisons with people that I
didn't
I didn't care about I didn't know but I
thought it would fix me you'd think God
these people are so honest it's
I've I realized the power in honesty I
mean that's your thing right
Speak Your Truth yeah
powerful yeah
freeing oneself isn't it hmm
so I learned I learned everything to
help me I did have like
another transformational moment
when I got hypnotized
um for a job that I was doing about
eight years ago
and that was like
that was when the impermeable seal went
on my fear of Abandonment and it was
unexpected because I wasn't going to the
hypnotist about that I was going to the
hypnotist about
not feeling anxious going in a submarine
to a thousand meters under the sea
tiny three-person submarine where you
can't stand up and there's no loo and it
takes 40 minutes to get to the surface
again and I thought I don't get
claustrophobia but I don't want to find
out at a thousand meters under the sea
that I am indeed claustrophobic so I
thought I better go and get hypnotized
just to make sure
and that was have you ever done hypnosis
no ah man I mean if you've got an issue
that
is something that you've worked on a lot
and it's hard to let go of
I mean I didn't even think really that
my fear of Abandonment issue was still
there but I do think
I do think it was and we did some
regression work
where I went back to me in the kitchen
looking at my granny thinking my mom's
not going to come back
and I don't know what to do and I feel a
bit guilty
I think I've overstayed my welcome and
the hypnotist said go get go get that
Davina
take it by the hand he said where's your
favorite place in the garden
said the oak tree
so he said take her to the oak tree so I
took her over to the oak tree little me
four years old
and he said okay sit her down
and sat her down and he said you know
Comfort I said she looks worried
and he said comfort her
I said I feel silly I don't know what to
do it's me I it feels weird and he said
imagine she was one of your own children
comfort her as if she was your child
so I put I put my arm around her
and I thought okay this is easier and
then her head went on my on my chest and
I was stroking her hair
I said I don't know what to say
I kept thinking he's looking to me to
say something profound and I've got no
idea how to do this
and he said well why don't you tell her
it's all gonna be okay
and I really started crying like really
crying
and he said the same thing it was up
and I said it was not going to be okay
I take drugs I make stupid decisions I
put myself in danger it's bad
and he won't but look at you now
and it was like
oh my God
Look At Me Now
I'm great
and it was like everything went you know
all the cogs and the wheels and my brain
all went click
I am gonna be okay
I looked at her
and I got like her head in my hands and
I was like you are gonna be okay your
life
is going to be amazing
and it will be full of you know ups and
downs but you are going to be okay
and he said you can take it back
let's take her back so I went back to
the kitchen
to down in the seat and she's smiling at
me and then he says we can leave now but
he said before before we leave I want
you to just turn around and look at her
one last time and tell me what she looks
like
she looks happy
and he said great and then he brought me
around I was like bawling
this is amazing what's happened what's
just happened and he said
we've planted a seed and he said let's
just wait and see what happens there he
said this this was basically to stop you
feeling like you're gonna
be abandoned at the bottom of the sea
but actually I think maybe we've done
something bigger here it might be kind
of amazing what happens
and a couple of things happened after
that that where I said actually it's not
okay
uh to treat me like that I would never
have said that before because I was
worried you'd abandon me if I I stood up
to you and said
not okay I'd think oh you might not like
me anymore
I I it was very important that everybody
liked me
and suddenly I was like actually I can
stand up for myself in a non-aggressive
way
and not actually mind if you like me or
not because I'm doing it for me
oh my God it was
and I feel like from that moment I've
been a different person
in all of my decisions
in my outlook on life
it's been Mega so your your career then
in TV
one of the things I read is that it was
heavily fueled we kind of talked about
this before we start recording by your
desire to be famous yes I mean the the
first MTV thing so I I'd wanted to be a
singer another desire to be famous I
wasn't good enough I was like I would be
an amazing backing vocalist
I my my nickname at home is the
harmonizer I can't listen to a track
without harmonizing to it I absolutely
have to that's annoying at some point
then isn't it yeah because all my kids
are like oh my God in in the car I'm
always like hmm
and you know like if they're going oh my
God like stop if I could have turned my
family into the Von traps and I really
tried like that we all made them all do
choir I all had to kind of do singing
lessons they just weren't buying it at
all and I'm so upset about that but if I
could have had the Von traps that would
have been my dream anyway
failed singer
what else can I do to get famous all of
this obviously mum
look at me
you made a mistake
look how great I am that's at the back
of everything right
and
I mean for example when I was 15 or 16
and I I did quite well in my o levels
they were o levels back then how old I
am and um I called up my mum to tell her
I'd done quite well on my own levels she
was really angry
because she felt like I was just trying
to show her up or that you know don't
think that you're she was drunk she was
drunk she took it badly she's like felt
that it was me trying to say that she
wasn't good enough or that she'd done
something you know I and I was so
confused by that
um that I thought I'm gonna show you
like I'm gonna make you want to
anyway my aim was I want to get my own
show on MTV that's what I want and I got
my own show on MTV and I presented the
first show and I went up to the dressing
room afterwards and I cried and I cried
and I cried and I couldn't figure out
why I was crying and I called my sponsor
which is something you you have a
Narcotics Anonymous who's there to help
you decipher yourself
and she said right you know we picked it
apart and picked it apart
and I said it hasn't fixed the whole
it
it didn't make me think oh my mum's
gonna want me back and then to top it
all off my mum did call me and say she'd
seen it because you could see it in
France because it was European
and she said what you know you think you
should stop pulling the faces you pull
these faces and I was like
that was not the desired effect I did
not want you to think that I wanted you
to think wow you're amazing you know
and um
so it was
a really
heavy moment and then I thought wow I
need to warn everybody
you know being famous
you've got to do it for the right
reasons I did it for the wrong reasons
and now I'm here and I've got this job
and I'm on the wheel and I don't know
how to you know I can't get off I didn't
want to get off I mean I was enjoying my
job don't get me wrong working MTV were
some of the greatest years of my life my
life but
actually it was probably his life so
I've had lived about 10 different lives
in my lifetime
and MTV was one of them
but I think that that realization that
the thing that I'd been aiming for that
I thought was gonna fix me and it didn't
was like again the end of something
and the start of another phase of my
life okay well you're gonna have to find
it inside
somehow
and that that hole You referred to is
that whole filled now filled
yeah I mean I've 100 I've never been so
happy
like I can't even
I sat oh
do you know it was really funny because
I said I said
to my boyfriend this morning I said I'm
going to do this thing with Stephen
Bartlett this morning and he was like oh
my God I said I am not going to cry
I'm like
I haven't done Piers Morgan specifically
for this reason because I was like I am
not gonna sit under but it's weird
because it's the thing it's took I could
talk about my pain until the cows come
home and not feel a thing because it's
so far removed from me and it was a long
time ago and I've processed and
processed and processed it
but feeling happy like is so alien like
a hundred percent like joyous
sitting on the train
and just feeling so good this morning
and it's not like
um Euphoria or a druggy happy or a fake
high it's content
oh my God it's like I can't I cannot
quite believe it
and I'd and I don't
you know I've been walking forwards
but I don't know how I got here just
walked forwards
you know but settling settling down
um I feel like I've I've grounded in a
way that I've never had before
and you know I think it's so important
to talk about this stuff because
at 55 if you'd have said to 30 year old
me
what's life going to look like when
you're 55 I'm gonna say really sad
I probably won't be doing
TV anymore it won't want me and I'd be
really boring
and I won't be having fun anymore and so
and I think I could be wrong or wrong
like I've got to go and tell everybody
quick tell everyone it's gonna be okay
Stephen
it's gonna be okay
never had someone say to me that
their feelings of Happiness make them
emotional oh
and when I think about it oh well
because I'm grateful and I think because
you know we were talking about what
makes you a positive person
I think it's because you think it it's
been a roller coaster right it's it's
for you it's been a roller coaster
but like it's not about the lambo or the
house or the Mansion it's about this and
your roller coaster and your journey to
money and making it and then realizing
it doesn't fix you and then you fixing
Yourself by being on a journey of
self-discovery which
you massively are by talking to all
these different people you're like
taking little bits from everything that
somebody says to you and think I'm going
to use this for me that was a great tool
thank you very much I'm going to have
that
it's like you are healing yourself this
is your n a meeting this is this is your
this is your recovery
yeah this is your recovery and how
amazing is that great it's crazy
privileged yeah but in you know and it's
just gonna these are all seeds that are
planted in you that just continue to
grow
so life gets better you know Mother
Nature throws you crepey knees and
crepey elbows and crow's feet
that it also throws you a full heart and
a peaceful mind
your career your your career in TV that
whole journey it's been one of the most
incredible
careers that I think most people could
ever hope for in any industry ever you
know you the top of your your game
um I first came to learn about you
because of big brother but there's a
career before that and there's a long
long career
after that
when you reflect on what advice you
would have given yourself or like why
you made it to the very top of that that
pyramid what is the answer Davina
this is another thing that I Marvel at
every day because
I've been many times in my career where
I've thought
this is it it was interesting after Big
Brother finished
um I contacted a friend of mine who was
like a tech
attacked a techie person
and I'd had this thought like after big
brother I thought who am I
and where am I gonna go and it could all
end and as the person that was
providing the roof and the food on the
table it was on like me I had to think
of my next step what was I going to do
I'm not sure how long television is
going to last I mean it's still going
which is amazing for me but
I thought I need to get into technology
and the internet and I need to go online
and I came up with an idea for
I thought about it in terms of an
Exhibition Center but you could put that
online where
you would have everything from money
advice personal advice mental advice
um kids advice I went and talked to a
few people about it and for whatever
reason it didn't happen
but it wasn't meant to happen I tried to
get it off the ground for like two or
three years I tried to make it a TV
program I tried to make it an exhibition
I tried to make it an online thing and
you know when you're
swimming against the tide with an idea
and at some point you've just got to
take your hands off the steering wheel
and go like that wasn't meant to happen
but then I got offered long lost family
now long lost family I've been filming
that program now for 13 years wow it
makes me feel so good that show and I've
helped so many people
on it which has been so wonderful to be
part of that moment in their life where
they learn something that's been a niche
that they couldn't scratch for years and
years and we can provide that scratch
um so I always think well just start
walking in that direction
and something else will come along but
never just sit down and wait
you know I've never sat down and thought
Oh I'm just gonna I'm just gonna stay
here and and wait for something to
happen to me I've got no embarrassment
or Shame about emailing a TV company or
a head of a TV company and going have
you thought about this what about this
can I present that if it happens can I
do this I've I'm literally begging ITV
to let me present mid-life love Island
I could fill a villa
in love island with middle-aged people
with the best backstories you have ever
heard in your life they've lived a life
they're widows they're people who have
been through horrific divorces they are
people who have split up with somebody
and decided they want to try going out
with somebody the same sex as them
they're like interesting people I'd
watch
that's really interesting yeah and I was
like I need to present it please what
are they saying they said oh we're
looking at something else that's quite
similar we might consider you for that
well if I hadn't sent them that email in
the first place they wouldn't have
thought about me for the other show
Maybe
you've got to make opportunities happen
they never just come to you
keep walking I'm always talking to my
kids just keep walking something will
come kind of form
build the foundations and just keep
walking as you're walking you're laying
more and more path
don't sit and wait for the path to be
laid because it'll never come to you
there's this word manifestation you've
used in this conversation what role and
what does that mean to you you know
you're talking there about
proactively like attacking the day I I
almost liken it to um the analogy I've
given before is when you get in your car
in the morning you set the sat nav which
is the manifestation but then you've got
to drive if you just do one if you just
drive you're gonna get lost if you just
set the satellite if you're going to be
in your garage all day you have to do
both together you've talked about how
you attack like send the email make the
phone call pass to the person at MTV but
then what role does like the
manifestation play
in all of that it's interesting because
you said you've got it's all very well
putting it in the sat nav is the
manifestation but then you've got to
drive the car yeah but in in my mind I
see that if you start if you know where
you're going
your car self-drives
like
you you almost are always walking in the
direction because you can see it
I know that at some point I will do this
interesting so I've sent this email to
this woman
um and I've just told you about it
because this this was a manifestation
it's triggered my memory that I've told
this I'm going to send a follow-up email
today
now is that is is my car self-driving it
kind of is like because I've been
telling you about a manifestation
because I had it in the first place
you've just reminded me I'm going to
send the email that for me is the
difference though because there's so
many people and we all know them that
have
sofa ideas they'll turn to you while
they're watching yeah I've got this idea
for this TV show sometimes they're
really good right fantastic but it
doesn't matter because they don't have
the the next bit which is I'm gonna get
up and send an email and like you've
just said I'm gonna send another one
that for me is turning the key in the in
the ignition yes maybe yeah some there's
a lot of people that are going oh I've
sat now for Tom Tom this is where I want
to go someday and then they just relax
back into the chair in the car and
nothing happens and then there's some
people I meet tends to be the people
that sit here with me that took that
weird kind of um nothing to lose first
step and you go that was rude or you go
oh really you just like all showed up
there or you just begged them on email
and those are the people that I tend to
sit here with
so Anita Roddick started the body shop
and she lit kind of my
um lit the wick of kind of interest in
lit the fuse I mean of my interest in
activism and she was saying
um you know if you don't think that you
have the power as one person then you've
never been to bed with a mosquito she
said be as annoying as a mosquito and I
was like
I think that's me I am as annoying as a
mosquito
and that when I meet somebody and I bet
you're the same Stephen when you see a
kid and a kid comes up to you and goes
Stephen can I have your number because
I've got an idea and I want to come and
Pitch it to you you would go yes
absolutely whereas other people might
think oh I can't do that because he's
Stephen Bartlett or I'll have to email
him or oh no I've seen him on the Telly
I can't approach him but when you meet a
bullsey kid yeah and they go can I come
and Shadow you for a day or
um uh give me a number I wanna you think
yeah sure because I always respect the
the tenacity and the asking I see myself
in it a little bit exactly yeah I
remember I was doing this podcast one
day and um I was recording with a guest
and then I got up to walk out and the
the person they brought with them in
their Entourage was their nepheus and
she goes to me hi Stephen I know this is
I know you're leaving and I know you've
just interviewed my auntie but I have a
podcast I've just started and I would
like you to be on it so can we record it
now did you say yes I was like of course
I was like let's sit down and we sat
down and recorded for like 45 minutes
for her podcast stop
isn't it she and she's killing it now
like when I say killing it she's
actually killing it she's like killing
it now but I remember doing a post on
LinkedIn about that moment tagged her in
it and said I just respect the ask you
know because my life has been riddled
with moments as I saw in yours where I
just sent the email had nothing to lose
whilst sucking stealing pizzas on my own
in Manchester what did I have to lose at
that point by just sending loads of
emails I remember Sam's I think it was
Panasonic or Samsung gave me free
cameras I sent an email they were like
here's all the free cameras to start
your business when I was 14 I sent these
emails to this vending machine company
they fitos secondary school with free
vending machines that we made profit
from so I I'd learned the power of just
like asking
nothing to lose maybe my ego might take
an out but he gives a [ __ ] I've got
nothing and what's the worst that could
happen but I think also when the worst
has happened yeah you're not scared of
it it's happened yeah yeah
you know getting a no to me is just a
yes that hasn't happened yet I'm always
like oh
you're saying No but
you mean maybe you mean maybe give me an
ask again
quick one some of you know Intel are
sponsoring this podcast and for me Intel
has made the search for a premium laptop
so much easier by creating the Intel Evo
platform which is signified by this
sticker here in the corner laptop
designs only receive the Intel Evo badge
when they have been tested to pass
Intel's own very strict requirements so
that they can actually perform as you
need them to out in the real world and
the result for me is a premium laptop
that can perform everywhere even with my
crazy schedule in mind and most
importantly it can handle multiple tabs
open and a battery that really lasts
throughout the entirety of my meetings
whenever you need your laptop for Intel
Evo have you covered it's a game changer
to find out more and to get your hands
on an Intel Evo laptop go to intel.co.uk
Evo and let me know how you get on quick
one for many years people have been
asking for a coffee flavored heel and
quite recently he'll release the iced
coffee caramel flavor of their
um ready to drink heels and I've just
become looked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
heels ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about your
the podcast I sat here with Professor
Galloway Scott Galloway and he told me
about the Ark of Happiness where he says
you know his idea was that our happiness
kind of looks like a bit like a smile
where kind of start happy at the start
of our life it gets a little bit
difficult in the middle and then at the
end the kind of 50-ish age when we go
into that second spring it's it's happy
again typically again this is not the
same for everybody it's kind of a
generalization but at the bottom of the
Arc of Happiness when things are most
difficult is when we start losing people
in our lives that we love
and I know 10 years ago you lost
Caroline your half-sister
um
talk to me about that that experience
and also
generally the process of how you've
dealt with that grief hmm
it was definitely the worst thing that
ever happened to me still to this day
like the worst
so I told you a little bit about
Caroline with my mum and that she she
was six years older than me
and she lived in Paris she was the
result of my mum's pregnancy when she
was 16.
and she endured a lot
well a lifetime with our mum and that
was very hard on her and she was left
with many Hang-Ups from that
of um she was she she used to find it
hard to be completely honest all the
time so she'd tell big exaggerations
about things or make up stories but this
is because she'd had to lie to cover for
my mum her entire life
not all the time but just she'd make her
life a bit more exciting
by telling untruths and I I don't want
to do her a disservice in her death
because we talked about this when she
was alive and I go is that a Porky and
she'd start laughing she'd go well it
did happen but this didn't happen you
know but it was just trying
I understood her and she understood me
and all my defects of character
and she knew exactly why I did things
and she was an instiller person quite an
insular person and her favorite thing
would be to go she lived with me always
we had six dark years when we didn't
live together but she lived with me when
I had a two bed flat in Hammersmith
and
we were very friendly together like I
just understood everything about her and
she understood all my idiosyncrasies and
I got all of hers
and so her favorite thing in the evening
you know I love socializing I'm a people
person I like going out I am touch
she would be TV dinner food on lap foie
gras a ton of butter French bread gloss
of red wine spliff
if I would say to her do you want to
come for a walk around the garden she
was French fully French so her mum and
her dad were friends
and I'd say do you want to come for a
walk around the garden she'd go no
you know exercise not her thing
absolutely hilarious person so funny
but very secretive
and I was blah I would tell her
everything she would tell me nothing
it was very annoying
um I would walk around naked
in front of her all the time I go
come I'd find out I go Caroline come
come and talk to me when I have a bath I
mean I was so annoying I was an annoying
little sister right until the very end
so she'd come over to the house and
she'd sit on the floor and I'd go like
talk to me tell me everything what's
happened at work blah blah blah and then
I'd share something I'd talk about a
problem and she'd help me iron it out
she was amazing so good to talk to so
kind of wise always a bit painfully
honest with me yeah but you know you're
overstepping the Mark or you know you
shouldn't be doing this she's the only
person that could do that with me
but because she was so secretive things
were going a bit arise so she just had
her 50th birthday
and
she
sort of walked into a door once a door
was half open and she kind of walked
into I was like didn't you see that I
thought she's been
um and then she was sitting at the table
and she was talking to me and she had a
glass in her right her left hand it was
her left hand she had a glass in her
left hand and now she was talking to me
I was watching the glass her left hand
was tipping further and further over to
the side and I was watching the glass
and the water was just and I went
Caroline your hand and she went oh but
she had to look at it to tip it back up
and I was thinking that's very weird and
she became a bit clumsy and I thought
too much weed or menopause or something
she became a bit forgetful
she kept going off menopause I can't
remember what's going on
she had a sore back and she'd fallen
over we'd been in the garden and she'd
fallen over
and she kept going you know and I fell
over my back's like still not right she
used to cane the Advil I mean she was
terrible with like painkillers
she used to take sleeping pills you know
she's slightly medicate herself weed
sleeping pills Advil like all the time I
just thought she's on another planet
but it got to the point where I thought
something is up and I'd invited her to
come to France with us for half term she
always came on holiday with us and she
said no
which was very unlike her and I was like
are you sure she went I just want to
stay here I'm so tired I don't feel just
feel like I've got flu coming on I was
like okay
I got back she'd have flu all week she'd
been in bed all week I was like whoa
Caroline like but I think maybe you
should go see something she said no I
think I'm coming out of it then the next
morning
someone had been walking past our window
and they said
um to be nothing you should come I can
hear Caroline shouting for help so I've
got the key I opened the door she'd been
on the floor all night
um she was in her pajamas she soiled
herself she couldn't move she was
paralyzed down half her body and I was
like it's a stroke
quick call the ambulance the quicker we
can get our scene the better the rat car
comes the you know stroke X but he walks
in he goes
I don't think this is a stroke I was
like but it must be a stroke because
half her body's gone like this is what
happens in a stroke
they get her in an ambulance I'm now a
bit worried
I'm thinking if this isn't a stroke what
is going on
but I was just trying to be strong for
her I just go it's gonna be fine we're
going to get you to hospital and they're
going to get it sorted it's probably
you know bit menopause bit of whatever
maybe you're smoking too much we get out
of the hospital test after test after
test and I was thinking brain scan I
understand
and then they said we'd like to do a
chest x-ray and I was thinking why are
you doing a chest x-ray
if it's clearly neurological
or she goes to the chest x-ray and then
about an hour later we get a doctor come
in and he goes
we've got something to tell you
we're both thinking yeah we're in a e
right
and he goes yeah you have primary lung
cancer in both lungs
and you have two brain tumors it's
metastasized to your brain and the pain
in your back is where your lung cancer
is then going into your bone
so you probably have bone cancer as well
I was like
like that can't be right and she went
lung cancer and then she looked at me
and she went
it's all my fault
when it's not your fault
like it's not your fault you've got lung
cancer
and she could see her just going tick
tick tick smoking all those years
smoking they're smoking the weed and I
was like stop stop we need to think like
what are we gonna do like okay
what are we gonna do in the meantime I
have to I just said I'm just gonna go
and call
um my mum and dad I'm just gonna go and
call them and just let them know what's
happening
and I called them I
couldn't breathe I was like in the
corridor going I think I think I'm I
think I'm gonna have like some kind of
attack like I can't
I can't process it I don't understand
what's happening
that I think they're telling me because
they hadn't said the word die I think
they're telling me Caroline's dying like
she's got so much cancer that she's
dying
I said I'll I'll keep you posted I go
freshen up my face I there was a nurse
there that I've seen a couple of times
since when I've taken my kids into a e
and I always give her a bit of a special
hug because
she came up to me in the corridor
and she was like are you okay and I was
like I'm not okay she's like what's
going on I said well my sister's got
this and this and she was like really
sorry she just gave me a hug and that
was it and then she went but I've never
forgotten it you know that hug I needed
touch I needed someone to
I went back in kind of tried to dry off
my eyes or what have you and we just sat
there in silenced really and then lots
of people came in and were looking at
her
one of the saddest things was someone
lifted up her back to put the
stethoscope on the on her back and
listened to her
and
I saw another sign that sounds so weird
but I saw a black head on her back and
it was massive and it had grown into
kind of a a saw it looked horrible
and I thought
no one sees you
no one
no one sees you naked
no one
you don't let anyone in like I am the
closest and even I am not in
because you are so protective of that
painful child she'd never done the work
she'd never got to na or AAA she wasn't
really an addict
I mean you know she smoked a lot of weed
but I didn't I didn't see her as that
she wasn't an alcoholic she wasn't
but she
she had she'd put a fence around her
and everybody was at the fence and she
had so many friends that loved her so
much but nobody got inside the fence and
I it made me so
so sad
and I thought I'm [ __ ] climbing over
the fence and I'm gonna get in
for however long you've got left because
you are not shutting me out we had the
best talks she was in hospital for a
month we had the most
amazing
brilliant talks like I thought God why
is it that when you're dying
we get to do this why did we not do this
a year ago like if anybody's listening
and they feel like they've got a
relative that they want to get into or
get do it now don't wait for someone to
die
because
the best seven weeks of my life with my
sister were those last seven weeks of
hers
and so she had a month in the hospital
and then
we I said I want to get her home
to her Cottage
I had to go around and find all her weed
and it was everywhere I literally could
have
you know started dealing she had that
much weed squirreled away I think she'd
forgotten half of the places that she'd
had it squirreled away
I chucked it all away
um I wasn't I didn't find that hard at
all like I wasn't I was never interested
in weed so it was easy for me I
um set up her house got the plumber in
put in things for her to hold
um occupational therapy came and told me
all the places where I need to put stuff
harnesses hospital beds blah blah blah
set up her whole Cottage got her back
home
and just hung out with her and we got a
carer and she she had chemo booked in
but the first chemo was booked in for
two days after she died
and we thought she had six months we
wrote a bucket list
and on the bucket list
was
um
just the sweetest stuff like go to
France one more time and
um see the kids we tried to make as much
of it happen get loads of her friends
down a lot of the stuff we couldn't do
again like why do people do bucket lists
when they're dying like do Bucket List
when you're alive and also I would
challenge anybody listening to this
podcast because this was a real thing
for me
if somebody said to me
Davina you have got
six months to live
what's like the most important thing to
you now
like what what really matters
don't wait for somebody to say that
you've got six weeks to live
say I love I say I love you to all of my
friends all of the people that I love
Non-Stop
check in with people call people make
sure they're okay spend time with people
make the decisions where you think if I
was to die tomorrow is this the decision
that I'd be happy with equally if you've
got somebody very toxic in your life and
they are really ruining your life
you know if you had six months to live
you would be the first thing I'd do is
let go of this toxic person do not wait
you know do it now and you deserve to be
happy
you deserve to not have this toxic
person in your life and Caroline
again I guess you know I'm always
looking for lessons she taught me so
much in her death she was so brave
she never once complained she never once
got frightened
she never cried and she tried to look
after me and one of my most I'm sorry
Stephen I know I'm talking a lot but
there was one moment I do want to tell
you about so obviously no one had ever
seen the naked and she had this amazing
caracal Claire oh my God
she was
the best ever
she was the most gentle she understood
respect
and dignity
and she knew Caroline almost straight
away she knew what kind of person she
was and Caroline would not let me
get her undressed or ready for bed
it was like I don't want you to see me
naked
and the night that she went to sleep for
the final time and then three days later
she died
she was doing this kind of knitting
thing with her hands she was really
uncomfortable you could see there was
something something had changed a bit
and I was like hey you okay and Claire
didn't come until maybe seven or eight
in the evening to to put her to bed with
the district nurse and um
and she said I I want to go to bed now I
know Claire was there but she needed
somebody else to put her to bed because
there was hoists and everything
and I said well look Claire and I could
do it but it would mean that it would be
me
and she went
okay but laughing and I was like are you
serious and she went yes and I went oh
my God Caroline thank you
thank you but at the same time I was
like well you know I'm gonna cry like
this is the
this is Mecca I've arrived you know
this is my pilgrimage to my sister I've
I crawled over the fence and I'm now at
her body
and I said to her would it be all right
if I did the dipra base because I needed
to dip a base her before she got into
bed so she didn't get bed sores and
that's like moisturizing every inch of
her body
and she went yes but you're not gonna do
it again like this is the only time I'm
going to let you do it once
and I said
and I got to she had the softer skin I'm
very furry
my my sister had no hair like at all she
was bald as a coot and her arms and
stuff was so soft I got the difference I
was like oh my God Caroline your arms
are so soft and she was laughing away
she's going oh my God you are ridiculous
it's gonna this is amazing
and I got to cream her whole body
and it felt like
she'd given that to me and it was
hideous for her
and even when she was dying
she gave me
a
bit
of herself that I had never had before
and it was so nice
and she went to sleep that night and
actually in the middle of the night then
they came
and they gave her a bit more morphine he
said okay she was really distressed she
was calling me mummy
and holding onto my hand she'd never
been like that before
and she
that gave her some morphine and it
calmed her down a bit and then
for three days she just slept basically
but I was with her when she went and it
was really lovely
and I kept talking to her the whole time
because they say your hearing is the
last thing that goes
and I just wanted her to know I wasn't
crying I was just trying to be really
strong for her and I kept saying to her
I'm gonna be fine because I think out of
everything
she was worried about me do you know
what I mean like that was her last
thought like are you gonna be all right
because she knew how much of a backbone
she was for me that's what I meant about
it being a reciprocal agreement like it
wasn't just me taking care of her she
was taking care of me and she it was a
reciprocal agreement and she wanted to
make sure that I was going to be all
right and I kept going I'm going to be
fine
and I talked out all the time but in the
last five years so I had a huge grieving
thing seven years after she died I went
like
all summer she died on the first of
August and all summer I couldn't shake
off this
cloud
and as somebody online interestingly had
said often seven years after someone's
died it's like a bang and I was like
this is what's happening to me seven
years like so painful again
since then you know and me being in a
good place I keep telling her I keep
going oh man like I wish
I wish you were here like so I could
show you how great it is she'd be living
with me now and
you know she'd be so
happy we'd be good I imagine myself I
always thought that I'd be willing her
around I always imagined she'd probably
get emphysema and she'd have an oxygen
tank and um but I'd tell her that I'd go
if you carry on doing that you're going
to get employment I said but I'm happy
to wheel you around I am we're going to
live by the seaside somewhere and you
and me can be a couple of old grannies
and I'll
you know I'll take care of you
but I didn't never thought she'd die at
50. but she was a great person
and um
but her
her passing my dad you know when he died
he had Alzheimer's and I it was expected
we knew it was coming we'd spent 10
years preparing for it it was still
horrific but he was 78.
and
I knew he'd lived an amazing life but I
still felt my sister had so much more to
give you know
foreign
what is that process of grief like uh
you know I ask these questions because
I've been fortunate enough to not go
through that Arc of grief yeah and I
think about it it's been like I think it
haunts me a little bit in my head
sometimes
um that process of grief what you
learned from it what you would um what
you might impart on me
do you ever feel like an island in your
life like
that your family all around you but
you're not quite attached like you are
slightly on your own 100 I always felt
like that too
so I'm sort of attached but not quite
attached and other people are attached
but I've never and it's not a bad thing
it's not because anybody's tried to
detach me I just feel like an island
maybe you didn't in my case I feel like
I didn't learn attachment I didn't learn
how to you know I call my parents by
their first names and I do you I don't
know you know I
feel like we're in a family of islands
that's called archipelago is that what
it's called yeah a group of islands all
groups
[Music]
so I I don't so your partner I know you
don't talk about personal life but is it
like two islands have come together so
you've formed a like a little it's
interesting like I said to Michael like
Michael's a beether and I'm Foreman
Terror oh yeah I'm the like the really
kind of gorgeous like hot beautiful
unsport island next and he's quite a
party island and we've formed like we've
now formed a Beethoven Foreman Terror
but we are two islands that have come
together
but I I I feel like
as as just to talk about the grief thing
I've my mum died my dad's died my
sisters died I have an amazing stepmom
who I love very much she's still with me
um but I have a half sister out in
Australia who I love very much but I
don't speak to
um as often because of the time
differences and everything
um and so now I really
I feel like an island I've got very
close family and stuff it's not that I'm
not close to my family but I do feel
but I've got all my kids are on my
Island they're with me they're in me
they're part of my DNA
um but it's just an interesting concept
that feeling you know but when you meet
somebody and you really get on with them
you can form a little Bond but you're
still two islands
but there's a bridge but there's a
bridge
funnily enough my girlfriend is the
opposite which is funny because I sat
here with a relationship matchmaking
expert and he talked about these three
different types of attachment that we
have one of them is like um evasive I
think that's what he said were you kind
of trying to avoid the prospect of
connection you self-sabotage you're
always trying to kind of run away from
commitment the middle one was nervous
where you're always very nervous about
attachment and that makes you needy and
then the third one he said was I'm gonna
paraphrase basically a stable we all
know those people
all of their parents are together still
they have you know that their parents
seem to be best friends and work
together they they end up being like
best friends with their partner they
just seem to have no problems and he
says it's it's a risk when two adverses
get together it's also a risk when an
aversive and a nervous get together
because you have someone who in my case
is trying to run you have a girlfriend
who wants attention and quality time and
I'm trying to run and she's trying to he
said you have to both together get to
becoming a stable together and I thought
that was
interesting because she has helped me to
become stable I don't run away
emotionally open affectionate but we
managed to get there together and maybe
that's the bridge maybe when you feel
you know
does any of that resonate with you yeah
totally yeah I mean I think I've prob
I'm in a stable for sure yeah were you
always
a stable attachment type in
relationships no because I had the fear
of Abandonment yeah but then this this I
feel like
this hypnotist
kind of transformed me to be able to
form healthy friendships
um change my whole outlook I think on
relationships
you wrote a book it's here in front of
me called menopausing why why did you
why did you want to write a book on it
writing books is a lot of effort yeah
you know so you have to really want want
it and you're you're now in a very
intentional phase of your life so this
must have really from everything I've
learned about you so far must have
really mattered
toasty I mean I think I did um I did two
documentaries which were eye openers for
me uh the first one was a huge risk and
I thought oh
am I literally committing professional
Harry Kiri here is is my entire career
going to implode now that I am
banging the menopause drum and telling
everybody that I'm menopausal because
I'd hidden it for so long
I thought is this going to be
a bad thing or a good thing I had no
idea but my life was heading to in this
direction where I'd been talking to
doctors and learning things and I
thought I've got a platform
and I don't understand when it's
something that happens to every single
woman it's not even like it happens to
some women items to every single woman
and some trans men
and we know nothing about it
this is a crime
to to Womanhood and it is also not good
for society
because women are behaving in a bizarre
and irrational and over emotional way
sometimes 75 percent of women have
symptoms 25 of women don't
those 75 are going to be behaving or
going through things that either will
affect their jobs their work certainly
will affect their relationships
certainly will affect their children's
lives if they've got kids
and yet we don't know anything about it
neither did you or you or like anybody
else know anything about what was going
on and I thought I have got a platform
and most of the people that follow me on
this platform are women I I've got I've
got to do something about it so I did
this first documentary and I kind of
watched that at home like that like oh
my God oh my God then I went out for a
dog walk the next day
it's always on the dog walk stop three
times yeah it's always on the dog but it
always goes off when I walk the dog it's
like amazing no and I got stopped three
times
and I was like oh hi yeah hi and they
went oh my God we watched it last night
I was like oh wow did you and then one
person cried another was a guy that
stopped me and said I watched it with my
wife and then we called my wife's sister
because my wife's sister's definitely
you know she's been like lost for so
long and it's so good and I thought God
I think this is going to be great I
think this is going to really help
people this could be seriously good
but like page one of menopause questions
I still get asked can I take HRT well
I've still got periods yes that is
exactly when
it's the best time to take HRT oh my GPS
told me I'm too young no 45 is a
completely normal time
you're thinking wow
I'm not reaching as many people as I
thought I was I've made these two
programs and I've talked about it and
I've shared about it and I've shared
about it online and I've said you can
watch it on all four and all of that but
I just thought there needs to be
something where it can be on a table or
in a loo or in a library or in an office
space where people can go and reference
and look something up and know that they
are getting 100 correct facts because
the doctor that I wrote this with
is unlike me
extremely fastidious about telling the
truth and about getting correct
scientifically validated information out
there
so me and her make quite a good team
because I'm all the kind of huge
feelings and passion and anger and
laughter and silliness and she's the
science
what are the symptoms and what symptoms
did you experience in your life because
there'll be people listening to this now
that are thinking oh they might have
seen they might know someone yeah you
know I thought about people that I know
when I first started learning about
menopause from actually Gabby Logan who
said she actually you played a huge role
in in her journey and her sort of
figuring all of that stuff out but what
are those symptoms to be looking for and
how much do they impact one's life and
relationships
so the symptoms can be varied they can
you can just get one symptom and it can
absolutely floor you or you could get
five symptoms and they don't massively
bother you or you might not get any
symptoms at all so 25 of women go
through it with absolutely like sell
through don't even know that it's
happened until their periods have
stopped
then 50 of women struggle a bit like I
would put myself in that 50 I struggled
quite a bit and then 25 of women it will
be so bad that they will think extremely
dark thoughts often suicide
um will feel complete hopelessness have
to leave their jobs have to leave
relationships or get left
um it has catastrophic effects on their
life so the the symptoms
estrogen depletion and estrogen affects
every organ in your body so
forgetfulness brain fog I mean that is
yeah where the [ __ ] my keys well done
chapter in the book Thank you love that
Stephen thank you
um
you know the the the forgetfulness is
epic
um and embarrassing and also another
thing that makes you feel old overnight
your body starts changing
um a bit of extra weight around the
middle because
um Professor Tim Spector now explained
to me that women metabolize sugar
differently uh in midlife and estrogen
and
um the way that that affects your
digestive system and your gut changes in
menopause that's like fascinating so
many changes happen
and so I had night sweats I had the mood
things I had
um
but all of the the the brain fog was the
thing that was really affecting my work
and I just thought I'm not even sure
that I can continue working but I did
end up through a long process and it's
all explained in the book but end up
seeing a private doctor and I'm sad that
I had to go to a private doctor but I
seriously thought I was going mad and
somebody flagged up maybe it is the
perimenopause but I said I've been told
by my GP I'm too young they said well
maybe go and you know paying go and see
somebody so I did and they said
immediately your perimenopausal
I had I've got hypothyroidism I've had
that since I was 28.
where my thyroid is under active and
apparently people who have
hypothyroidism can start menopause early
I didn't know that and they talked me
through all the perceived risks and the
benefits I didn't know there were any
benefits to taking HRT either
I thought it was only going to give me
breast cancer I thought it might take
away my symptoms which would be the only
benefit but actually there are health
benefits to taking it and I weighed it
all up and I thought I'm definitely
definitely going to go on HRT you can
take it for the rest of your life we get
asked that a lot you get asked like does
it postpone your menopause it doesn't
postpone your menopause but if you stop
taking it you've wean yourself off you
can occasionally get nod flush even
after your periods have stopped
um it's just the estrogen depletion in
your body if you keep taking the
estrogen you probably won't have the hot
flushes but some women have to stop
because they do get breast cancer that's
estrogen receptive and then
um
they are required but I met somebody the
other day who'd had breast cancer and
um she'd gone on HRT because she felt
the quality of her life was so bad that
she had sat down and weighed up look if
it comes back how are we going to deal
with it what would I do how many times
do I get checked a year and she weighed
that up herself but is a very personal
decision someone would be like I don't
want to take that risk I don't want to
take the risk of getting cancer just to
make myself feel better but for her she
felt so bad that it was worth the risk
so it's a very personal Journey
for so many women but it is a journey
that
when you know about it and you know
what's happening to you is an easier
journey to take what about men
you talk about men in the book yeah so
they're like really important I'm going
to tell you a story about a guy the
other day sent me a tweet and he said I
got your book and I went to the living
room door and I opened the living room
door I chucked in the book and I ran
away
and it made me laugh and I read it and
and I thought oh you know banter
hilarious yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm terrified and then I thought
actually do you know what I'm gonna send
you a direct message so I messaged him
because he was following me so I
messaged him privately
I said are you okay
and he went it's actually quite hard
like I don't know what to do
and I thought oh
that was a bit of banter but actually
you're struggling right so I was like
Hey listen I've got a great tip
leave the banter at the door of the
living room and why don't you go in and
you can pick up the book and sit down
and read it with her she'd absolutely
love it I can't tell you how much it
would mean to her if you said I'm I'm I
don't know what to say or how to help
you and I'm feeling tell her how you
feel
but in a non-comedy way like really tell
her how you feel and then say
what can I do to help
can I can I read this book with you can
we you know what can I do
anyway the next day sent me another
message and he went oh my God I did it
and it was so good and we read a bit of
the book together and I feel much better
informed and I don't feel like it's me
because I think he thought
it was him you know and being
it's hard to explain when you're being a
[ __ ]
that it's not their fault but that
everything that they do makes you want
to
like run away or shout at them but it's
not their fault how can that not feel
like your fault when you've got somebody
doing that to you
and just knowing that
it is a thing that happens and that
there are things that you can do about
it
makes all the difference you know to a
man
so I think and to the woman you know for
a man to then go oh I see it's like oh
he gets it do you know what though
there's um there's a fear I have about
this because
even in the case of him buying the book
and then running in I know it was a joke
running in there throwing it in there
and closing the door as if it's a
grenade or something
there's a there's a fear as a man that
if I was to approach my partner with the
book it would be me saying there's
something wrong with you yeah hmm I mean
see what I mean that is why
um an honest and open conversation about
how you're feeling not like you've been
a bit Moody recently I bought you this
book to say look yeah like say if a man
was listening to this and he thought
that his partner was perimenopausal
and they've maybe noticed three or four
symptoms by the book read it or have a
look at the symptoms if you're worried
about what they might think hide it and
read it look at the symptoms do a little
mental checklist I think you've got this
this and this and then go look
I've been feeling like this recently
I've been feeling like you don't love me
anymore and I really miss you say
something nice say something about how
you feel like we've Grown Apart a bit
and I want to bring it back and I've
been thinking and I've listened to some
stuff and I heard something on the radio
or you know how did you hear about this
book so then you say well I was
listening to the podcast Diary of a CEO
and I like And subscribe and so I
thought I'd buy the book and have a look
at it and I think some of this is can I
show you something can we sit down I'd
really like to show it to you and if
they get annoyed
don't worry they might get annoyed and
walk away and go I'm not perimenopausal
and then come back and secretly read the
book or they might come back and go I'm
sorry I I was annoyed but I think I am
and then they might have a cry
it can work out a million different ways
but it just needs a bit of patience
bit of understanding
and no banter
banter is like bad in several situations
banter is bad around periods
do not do banter back periods you can do
banter about haircuts clothing uh loads
of things but banter about periods are
not funny banter in childbirth
not funny
and this wife has given you permission
to Banff
uh unless you bounce at you then you can
bump back
and banter during menopause
unless she bands first
I always go by the womb because these
are times of great vulnerability
and sometimes a bit of banter can really
hurt
we use the word Omission earlier on we
used it in the context of once you
decouple from the need for validation or
to fill that hole you can have a much
more intrinsic internal mission to set
your life
um in a new trajectory
what is your mission now as you sit here
you said you're 55. um what is your
mission
I really like
helping people
so I think that's a general Mission if I
can help in any way like what can I do
to help you
I think I've got a platform you've got a
platform
you're helping people
you know that's like I feel like that's
your mission to spread
spread good using your platform I guess
like I've I've worked hard all my life
to get a platform now I've got a
platform what am I going to do with it
do I want to make more money or get more
followers really I'm not really bothered
do I want to help people yeah
so everything is like is this going to
help anyone is this going to do any good
even something is kind of
you know lingerie to me is a is a
superpower like lingerie is one of the
most important Builders of
self-confidence
when I was single I used to wear badass
lingerie because the First Act of
self-love is what are you going to put
on Underneath Your Clothes that's next
to your skin that no one else is going
to see that only you know what you're
wearing
you know I I see women who look
absolutely amazing on the outside but
they're wearing gray holy underwear and
it's a Act of care self-care is looking
looking nice only for you it's an
amazing Act of love so I want to help
people feel good about themselves I want
to get the message out there and I also
what do I want to do yes I just think
that is my mission I'm always thinking
about jobs like
because of my sister thinking about a TV
program I'd love to do called Legacy
because my sister was a beautiful person
and I never think she felt it but my God
her funeral was amazing and she was
loved so much and I kept thinking why
aren't you here oh my God you'd love
this you had no idea how much you were
loved how what a huge impact you had on
so many people's lives I thought
wouldn't it be great to do a sort of
this is your life type TV program where
you bring all the people together but
for somebody that is life limited
somebody who has a year left
and you do their funeral before they die
have a have a living wake for them
wow yeah it's like it's horrific but
great at the same time and if you found
somebody that was willing I would love
that
yeah I was thinking about it from my TV
the TV's perspective but wow what a
range of emotions this is your legacy
look all these people hmm
and getting the Roses while you can
still smell them yeah
so that's kind of that kind of thing
like I can do a job and and do something
lovely I mean I'm not sure if I would
find anybody to get that off the ground
because it's
it's quite extreme but this is yeah
I've said it out loud on here someone
might hear it you never know you are
you're such a legend for so many reasons
you have a real talent which I didn't
realize until I really met you here
having watched you on TV but there's
just something really quite electric and
and wonderful about you but that's
probably why you were so successful on
on TV in the public domain because
there's this electricity to you and if
anyone's ever told you that before this
real just like brilliant engaging
electricity so
um it's been an incredible honor to meet
you I've learned so much I felt a full
the full range of emotions your podcast
is fantastic which you do with Michael
making the cut yeah can I tell you
something funny please on Apple podcast
they Michael my partner is called
Michael Douglas and they've got a
picture of actual Michael Douglas with
me and I keep thinking Catherine Zeta
Jones is going to come over and like
love me go are you doing something with
my husband okay no they've got the wrong
picture up there I've written to Apple
so many times I've gone yeah I have I
keep writing to Apple podcasts going
mate please swap Michael Douglas's photo
for my Michael Douglas I'm going to get
into trouble with Catherine okay
fantastic podcast you sit there with
your partner and you talk about life
recommend things so we recommended in
fact the specific episode and we were
recommending your podcast in general but
the specific one was the Jimmy Carr one
which was he was a great such an
interesting mind-blowing mind-blowing
yeah yeah I saw that I think I dm'd you
after yeah you did you did if it was
straight after that no it was after that
it was after you've done a story about
it as well yeah so thank you for that we
all freaked out a little bit because
you're such a legendary oh my God
it is super surreal for me because you
know I've watched you on screens and
I've admired you for so long so to hear
that you were listening it's like oh my
God what did we say you know say thank
you you say good things it's okay and
your book is amazing we were talking
before you um we started about how the
way you've designed this book from the
colors to the cover to the the structure
of every page and how engaging and
unintimidating it is and accessible it
feels
um is also intentional you've done it
all for a reason I want it easy to read
I was just saying earlier about the the
hands on the front you know I wanted
those two hands at the bottom to look
like I'm gonna help you out of this and
we're gonna do it together
and that the messaging is positive
because I think people
um I had viewed the menopause as an
incredibly negative thing
um in my 30s and 40s and actually it's
been a time where you're actually
talking to me here and asking me how I
feel and I'm saying happy Yeah I mean
you know this is what menopausing has
done for me
I feel so happy
so I wanted to kind of convey that in
some way and make it a book that when
you are feeling diminished and invisible
that you can pick it up and it's easy to
read and you will see yourself in every
page
when I do this podcast sometimes I have
moments where I'm so grateful to get to
do this because because I meet these
amazing people but then I learn about
things that I like like it's like I'm in
a [ __ ] and I thought the room was fully
illuminated and then I have a
conversation about menopause and then
another light goes on that I don't even
know you know and it's like the rumors
just got bigger because someone has
turned the light on for me and learning
about menopause over the last from you
from this book from over the last from
what Gabby said and what you'd you know
the influence you've had on Gabby so
maybe oh [ __ ] else so many things
make sense now
um I mean well my mum had a medical
hysterectomy at 28 and would have been
plunged into the menopause and didn't
get HRT so I'm imagine what impact that
had on her and her behavior and her
actions
you know I I've I've forgiven my mum a
little bit for some I mean not all of it
but I've let go of it
um but I it's explained some of it
I actually did want to talk to you about
that situation of forgiveness with your
mother because
many people can relate to having someone
in your life that you fight to change
you try your best and you know because
they're your mum
um and at some point sometimes we have
to say listen
we've done more than we can possibly do
to the point that we're actually hurting
ourselves now
and we have to kind of cut ties as a bit
of a drastic way of saying it but we
have to kind of start protecting
ourselves
did that happen in your situation at
some point
so with my mum
um
she'd she was an alcoholic I then got
into recovery and then came the thing of
how long do I go along with my mum being
an alcoholic without saying you're an
alcoholic and you need to do something
about it because it's getting really bad
and
after a few years of being in recovery
talking to my sponsor going to meetings
sharing about it I thought I'm going to
confront her about it and I said you're
an alcoholic you need to do something
about it
and then she got really [ __ ] angry
with me and she didn't do anything about
it and I saw another couple of times she
was um stationed abroad with uh she'd
married her somebody that worked at a an
embassy
moving around
and eventually I just said look I can't
I can't see you until you get sober
and a couple of years later she went to
live in South Africa with her
husband
and she got sober
and I invited her to my wedding to
Matthew
and she came and she was sober and we
went to an NA meeting together
and we held hands and we shared
and then uh Matthew and I went on
honeymoon and we went to uh Paris
afterwards
saw my mum again it's kind of like
amazing like
it it was kind of as I had hoped it
would always be it was like a miracle
and then six months later on my birthday
on the 16th of October
just in case you want send me a card
next year
um
on the 16th of October I'm away in
Edinburgh and
paper comes upstairs and it says Mommy I
need a meeting on the front page of the
mirror
and I'd never spoken about going to
n a because it was an anonymous
fellowship and the point of being an
anonymous Fellowship is that
nobody knows you go
and she had sold a story to the papers
about us going to that meeting and the
papers had Twisted it so that it was
like I was about to relapse before my
wedding and that she'd taken me to this
meeting and you know saved sort of saved
me it was like that kind of tone
and then inside because I'm like you I
you know I've never printed pictures of
my children ever that I've never even
posted a picture of them on Facebook not
even on my private Facebook page ever
there's never been a picture of my kids
anywhere now my kids are 19 and 21 the
older ones they can choose I will never
post a picture of Chester online
there's pictures of our honeymoon
I like I hadn't I wasn't posted I wasn't
wouldn't I mean Instagram wasn't around
but there was she in the newspapers of
us like uh together with her
as like somebody taken my heart and
grabbed it and ripped it out and I felt
the shutters coming down I thought I
trusted you and I was you know I'd let
you back into my life and I'm gonna put
the [ __ ] shutters down because you're
not gonna get back in again I called up
and I was like what are you doing she
said oh it was the celebratory thing you
know that we'd gone to this meeting
together I said nobody knew I was in the
fellowship I said you go to the
fellowship you know it's an anonymous
Fellowship it's not like you you're new
to it you've been clean for a year like
what are you doing I was so upset and my
sister
who had always felt a bit invisible
was not mentioned in the article once
and my mum hadn't said I've got another
daughter or my daughter lives with you
know Davina and Caroline live together
or nothing she said nothing about a lot
she she was invisible
her so much
she never spoke to my mum again ever
from that moment
she was going to go over and see her in
South Africa they had a plain ticket
books and everything and then she
realized she probably bought the ticket
with the money that she got because my
mum didn't have any money I was giving
her money for medicines and things like
that she just was they didn't have much
money
and then I carried on giving them the
money because I thought
who do I want to be when I die
or when she dies I want to have been the
person that I respect so I thought I'm
not going to pull the money and not give
her her meds so I kept giving her the
money
and then every now and again she'd kind
of reach back in
I'd think oh my God this is different
than she'd do something else so another
story would come out or every time I
kind of reached out another story would
come out
and in the end
I found out she was dying of cancer
um in South Africa and I lay in bed in
England one night and
Matthew's asleep and I put my hands out
on top of the bed with my Palms facing
upwards
and I closed my eyes and I imagined
shoots of light of forgiveness coming
out of the palms of my hand going across
the world to South Africa to Pretoria
where she lived and straight into her
heart in the hospital
and I just kept saying I forgive you for
everything I just totally [ __ ]
forgive you I don't care anymore forgive
you go and like be go in peace
and then me my sister and my husband and
our kids all went away for a wedding in
America
and my sister and I got the news when we
were together
that she'd gone
and
I looked at her
and
I said she's gone
and she was like wow
and then we both had a little cry and
then Caroline looked at me and she went
relieved
said
I don't know
and I said God it's it's please don't
let and I said to her quietly then
please don't let me
be a person that dies and anybody ever
feels relieved about don't let me ever
live that life
and Caroline said me either
and Caroline definitely didn't we were
[ __ ] broken when she died so she she
achieved that and I hope that when I go
I don't ever like leave anybody feeling
happy that I've gone I'm not happy but
but when she died she freed me up to
remember
funny times as well as all of when she
was alive I could only remember the bad
and what I was missing and when she died
you know I was able to remember her
being hilarious and arresting people
drunk as the citizen's arrest or things
that
were just funny did you go to her
funeral no
and again will I regress it
no
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest
and the question left for you very good
handwriting
um is what makes you most angry about
Society
Council culture oh
have you been on the receiving end of it
yeah when
um
I wrote a tweet about
Sarah everard's death when it was
getting really nasty online about men
yeah
um
and
I said that
um
that abduction and death from abduction
is very rare
and we don't need to
completely Panic about that situation I
wasn't talking about any other kind of
things that happened to women I wasn't
talking about domestic abuse or any of
the other things that happened to women
I was just talking about abduction and
death from that it is rare and we just
have to
not start blaming all men because and I
was thinking about my son my son was
really cut up about it
and he didn't know how to behave he felt
like the enemy suddenly and I was trying
to explain to him that he was
I said you know we've got brothers and
husbands and kids
that are worried and what they want to
help Let's Not demonize all men
my God like I got 200 000 likes
um but I didn't see any of those I just
saw the 10 000 comments are asking for
me to be murdered or burned at the stake
or you know I'm a woman hater or I'm a
hashtag Not all men person and you know
don't understand about domestic violence
they don't know anything about my life
you know I've I've
like I've lived a life and I've
experienced a lot of really terrible
things and many terrible things have
happened to me but I just didn't feel
that this was the moment
to attack all men because in life I have
discovered that we need to come at life
together men and women segregating
everybody into groups separate groups
separatist groups I don't I think it's
anti-society
we need to all work together and
alienating people an entire
sex
is is not a good idea
well you know like we need you need to
have our back and we need to have your
back I know lots of men that really
changed their behavior
after hearing about how frightened women
are in the streets and you know like if
they're walking towards a woman just go
I said go or cross over the road to walk
on the other side and maybe they didn't
do that before that's a good thing like
we need to commend that rather than
well you know if we went front of you in
the first place you wouldn't have to do
that as you guys you know I just think
there's got to be a more open
conversation anyway counts cancel
culture so it's only happened to me once
I didn't take take it down I went to bed
for a weekend
and um I was ashamed I was ashamed and
frightened to go to
go shopping in my local supermarket I
didn't want to go out in town because I
felt like everybody'd read it and hated
me
and then I read quite a few articles
afterwards where they were saying no
completely understand where she was
coming from she was right and I was
thinking oh
oh right
and so I kept the comment up there
because I do stand by it
but I wish that I think my big mistake
and the thing that I should apologize
for is that I posted it three days after
four days after she died and it was
timing my timing was [ __ ]
um and it was way too soon and I did
again out of something that was really
bad a bad experience for me
I did learn something from it and I
won't do that again but I don't I think
canceling somebody doesn't let somebody
learn something and ruining someone's
life which
happens a lot
somebody's whole career gets finished
you're never letting them learn the
lesson they've got to you've got to let
them learn the lesson come back
and give them the space to say I could
have done it differently and I've
learned something yeah
yeah so it's I think it's a sad thing
that
and also it means that often
in the public domain I won't say
something that I think or believe in
because I'm really frightened I'm going
to get canceled for it and it might be
something quite mundane or small or
topic but I think we'll best avoid that
I don't know how we change that there is
some people in our society
you change that by stopping social media
because for the for the 10 000 people
that are verbalizing how much they hate
it two hundred thousand liked it yeah so
they agree but you only hear and
there'll be a lot of people who couldn't
even like it touch it yeah because of
the fear of because of the fear of
getting cancer that happens a lot none
of us are saying yeah what we think or
believe in or questioning something you
know it's terrible when you can't
question well why are you doing that
like is that a good idea I mean when we
stop this podcast I'm going to talk to
you about a couple of things that
happening at the moment which I think
are interesting but I can't say anything
I can't form an opinion about it because
I can't talk about it anywhere I need to
I need to find somebody I can actually
air it with you know it'll get clipped
and then it goes yeah it's terrifying
isn't it it's crazy because Shane comes
from that debate to the conversation the
questioning all of our progress in
society has come from that a
conversation Brave conversations with
ideas that at their time were maybe
denied or
um not believed in but because of
conversation progress because of the
Fearless nature of some people in our
society whether it's Martin Luther King
or you know the suffragettes whatever
things changed and we we can't do that
anymore with the nature of the world so
and how so how are things going to
change
there is there are some amongst us the
brave ones who who
seemingly don't give a [ __ ] and they are
taking all the arrows as they go and
we've got a like yeah it makes you ask
questions for that yeah yeah there are
you can think of those people I'm just
wondering like at what point at what age
am I because I've got a feeling I'm
gonna get to an age where I'm gonna go
[ __ ] it
I feel like JK Rowling just kind of went
for it at one point yeah but I feel like
that is another story altogether I was
just about to enter into it I thought
nope yeah yeah yeah don't want to get
canceled yeah okay well we'll finish
there I want to thank you so much again
it's a real honor to meet you and have a
conversation with you and um I hope we
do this again sometime because I feel
like we've got so much more to talk
about yeah me too yeah well we won't be
canceled but thanks for having me I
really enjoyed it and thanks for letting
me in to a bit of your life as well it's
been been a huge honor and I've really
it's been a rare and rich in
conversation because of your energy but
also because of your wisdom so thank you
hahaha
[Music]